winning winning is so delicious
yes
all right happy tuesday america let's
update you on the raid on mar-a-lago we
got never-before-seen footage roll it
[Music]
[Applause]
so like paul pelosi driving down a
two-way street
it's pretty obvious that merrick garland
crossed the line
and now the media realizes their whole
narrative is falling apart like a pot
roast and a hot tub
whatever happened to the story about the
nukes
yeah apparently trump stole valuable
nuclear secrets that he was planning to
sell to someone
i don't know about you but this seems
like a strange career transition for a
real estate tycoon
uh should i build a new luxury
condominium development in midtown or
sell nuclear secrets to putin
it's a tough call on one hand you can
make a lot of money legally on the other
you could be executed for treason
of course the media always picks the
most absurd crap to pedal about trump
so what is the media who invested so
much in this psychosis do now
they say if you dare criticize the raid
you'll be inciting violence against the
fbi who were busy doing the lord's work
of sniffing melania's shoes
i chose the word shoes
and true there were notable incitements
to violets there were remember michael
besloss tweeted a photo of the
rosenbergs who were executed for selling
nuclear secrets to moscow
it was a tweet that then general michael
hayden concurred with by adding sounds
about right that's two major voices not
calling out the fbi but suggesting the
execution of trump
but the media ignores that incitement
preferring to call out random nut jobs
posting threats on message boards but i
get it you should see the stuff i post
on the my little pony forums
but if you ever mess with twilight
sparkle i'll kill you
[Laughter]
but let's saunder over to cnn where wolf
blitzer the ugliest of santa's reindeer
[Laughter]
interviewed interviewed adam kinzinger
whose last name is german for i cry
during tampon commercials
and
wolfe asked the most leading question
you could possibly ask and no it wasn't
will you marry me roll it sven
you've seen this joint fbi department of
homeland security bulletin it's now
warning of what they call unprecedented
violent threats in the wake of the
search of mar-a-lago do you hold the
former president donald trump
responsible for inciting his supporters
yeah absolutely 100 wolf's any
republican elected official out there
that rushes to be the first on
television or the first to twitter to
basically condemn the fbi this stokes
that it's really dangerous and uh i fear
it could get worse
nah it could get worse he fears or hopes
but this is not journalism this is
emotional propaganda in which the host
indulges the damaged psyche of his
guests it's more manipulative than fox
running pizza commercials during my
hangover
so if you condemn the raid you're
stoking violence as opposed to best loss
in hayden actually suggesting trump is
eligible for execution
but who knows more about stoking
violence than cnn who've been
denigrating cops every chance they get
for the last 10 years
yet it's trump's fault for inciting
violence because he had somehow invited
the raid which could be the dumbest
thing you ever heard that didn't come
out of don lemon's mouth
even a clawed like adam knows it was the
raid that pissed people off there was no
incitement necessary but he's lost in
the rabbit hole of anti-trump mania
then when trump tries to reduce the heat
like a soothing cream applied to
hunter's latest rash
i don't know if that was necessary
listen to wolf's question and then the
answer from kinzinger
does it strike you as odd that the man
who actually set the fire apparently
tried to ask the attorney general to put
it out
yeah i mean it's it's a creepy message
to be honest with you just like frankly
donald trump and his supporters have
become quite creepy uh in how they're
acting and what and what they're
threatening
yeah
you know when adam calls someone creepy
it feels like projection
because absolutely there's nothing
creepy about a grown man who cries more
than a teething colicky baby with diaper
rash
but you start to see it's not trump
who's painting targets on people but
people like kinzinger who've been a
wreck since trump hit the political
scene amber heard hasn't cried as much
since she met johnny depp
it gets worse gets worse when wolf asks
about liz cheney the vice chair of the
jan six committee losing possibly losing
the gop primary he said this
i think it shows that the party's in a
bad place um look we are standing up
against evil liz cheney is standing up
against evil and i say this you know i i
put out this message the other day which
is a lot of people sit around and they
they dream about the day they get to do
it and very few people ever get that
chance to really stand up against evil
yeah they're fighting evil
what evil is that exactly is it
terrorists is it pedophiles is it field
gold kickers
no it's you
if you support trump you're evil if you
don't trust the government you're evil
if you don't trust the media you're evil
if you think that the fbi or the doj has
folks and top positions who make
political decisions instead of
principled ones you're evil meanwhile if
you're a blm writer a killer released
without bail a pervert teacher or the
chinese government nothing to see here
folks
so who's painting targets on people's
backs
it's adam he's sherwin
williams
remember
remember
in order to incite violence against
people you have to dehumanize them it's
an old tactic that charles krauthammer
stated decades ago the right thinks the
left is wrong but the left thinks the
right is evil what's funny is normally
to the left liz cheney would be the
evilest of evil
but how quickly the left forget the dead
now adam isn't a lefty but he's enjoying
the strange new respect
given from the left he's like a married
man getting hit on by an attractive
stranger except the attractive stranger
is named wolf and has breath that reeks
of polygrip
the libs get it
steering the emotionally damaged atom
toward conclusions no objective
republican would ever agree to
they've exploited his anti-trump mania
to their advantage because everywhere he
goes which is basically cable news and
twitter all this asshat sees are red
hats
he has long trumped arrangement and
there's no vaccine but it's given him
and cheney both a victim in hero complex
they're heroes for fighting evil and
victims when people call out their bs
and with that they forget the millions
of people who actually liked what trump
did as president they just aren't as
emotionally tied to trump's personality
as these brats are
so will liz win or lose
she pleaded for dems to switch parties
to help her and she got a late
endorsement from freddy krueger
plus
[Applause]
plus
she still has some pretty big fans
liz cheney stands up for the truth
uh and that's gotta hurt a lot of
heat
uh she may lose her position in the
party she may even lose her career as a
politician but that is something to be
admired standing up for the truth right
now i'm kind of a fan of liz cheney yes
[Applause]
oj claims he's a fan and it makes sense
they do have something in common
although oj stabs people in the front
[Applause]
tonight yes
he's so white he wears sunblock at night
fox news contributor tom salud
he filled the hole in my heart and
created one in bidlon's head former navy
seal and host of the new great podcast
the operator rob o'neal
like the parthenon he's famous for his
columns former federal prosecutor and
foxus contributor andy mccarthy
and she's like your phone screen bright
illuminating and covered in germs the
foxes contributor cat
[Applause]
all
tip
i got to come to you first andy because
you're kind of like the expert in this
aside from me of course
you know you're you know we're pros um
what do you make of this joint bulletin
to me it sounds exactly like the memo
about domestic terrorists being teachers
i mean being parents
you know the the joint bulletin on on uh
on um what did he call it the uh the
unprecedented threats against the fbi
you know i i just think they're in a
they're in a terrible place
right now um
you know the the threats obviously are
um
what they interpret to be threats
are people who are
troubled by
what happened in the raid and
you know the fact that they they're
given one story about what it's about
and then you know they get a look at the
warrant and it turns out to be about
something completely
different so i i think
when people protest
they want to regard it or they want to
portray it as if it were you know a
threat of of violence and in the
meantime if you want to see
who's been critical of the fbi
you're to look at the hundreds of pages
of reports that have been written by the
justice department's own inspector
general who works for merrick garland he
may maybe go down the hall and knock on
his door are you saying he is a
terrorist could be i mean
but that's the point of there are people
within the fbi the doj who are
hypercritical tom i do think you're evil
me yes you are evil
in this case i'll make an exception you
should be demonized well
you know what i can't stand it's the
phony indignance that's coming out of
the leadership and that's who everyone
is criticizing including people like you
or people like me when i'm on shows on
fox news whatever i say i don't like the
leadership i don't like what merrick
garland has done i don't like what
christopher wray has done and how he
won't stand they won't stand up they
won't uh you know have the courage of
their convictions and say what's in the
warrant things like that so we
criticized the leadership and then they
always say oh i think you're talking
about my agents yes and we're like no
actually i'm talking about you yeah wait
till my agents hear what you said about
them
it's like no we don't like the
leadership how dare you insult the rank
and file i mean they never stop with
that and we don't have a problem with
individual age we don't even know we
assume the agents are doing what they're
told plus we like cops and firemen you
know they say well are you right-wing or
are you supposed to support law
enforcement we still support law
enforcement cops firemen but if you wear
a suit into the fbi building you're not
you know you're not like a soldier
you're kind of in an office so you're
way down on the list i think you got
cops firemen basically the all the
village people like you know indian
chief cowboy
construction worker
[Applause]
then fbi agent after all those guys that
would have been weird to have fbi agent
in the village people
so rob yes you actually fought evil and
you killed evil so when you hear at i
don't know i mean adam king singer he
was in the air force yeah uh pilot he's
a friend of mine oh yeah and i think
he's i just trashed him in front of you
believe me being in the military we can
take a little bit there but i think what
he's doing here is he's taking a little
bit of stuff just a little too
personally right
he's in he's in the swamp right now and
the swamps one of those things where
they're dealing with party politics
that's the democrats they know that if
you can get someone to say something bad
about trump and trump supporters they're
going to do what they can i mean it's a
surprise we had uh oj up there just now
because i'm pretty sure what he said uh
recently was the same thing as uh
something with the democrats is it's
like comparing a battery to a fat girl
like it's gonna hurt but i'm going to
put my tongue on it anyway
right
so i don't even know what that means
but uh uh
but with uh trying to i'm trying to
figure out what that means you know
don't explain it to me i'd rather not
know but then you got with uh with the
cheney's coming out they're upset
because uh they're in you know they've
been in the politics forever and like
dick cheney shouldn't be upset about
anything because he's still rolling in
the millions from halliburton money
right and when he and i like he and i we
have something that's like not in common
i fought in the war he dodged a draft
but we do have in common we both shot
someone in the face
that's true
hunting accident
a hunting accident
so cat what's your take on this
incredible story that just doesn't seem
to end
yeah i can't handle all of the people
talking about liz cheney as this
champion for the truth i'm like you mean
the princess of the iraq war like her
and her truly like her dad of course but
also she propagating these lies that led
to a war and then after all of this
she'll probably go work at some weapons
company like some cog in the military
industrial complex that those same lies
help build up so i really can't handle
any of the moral outrage there are two
things to this one she would be
considered the eve most evil person on
the planet by the same people that are
interviewing her now but now that she
fits the she she provides a service
which is anti-trump and then to your
point
uh it was it
it was about trump kind of cleaning
house the cheney it was like he didn't
like the change yeah i mean i have a
theory on that it goes from uh
george bush to he was eight years as a
vice president four years president
george bush clinton all the whole
family's in there and that you know it
all comes back to the military
industrial complex yeah i mean yeah i
badmouth them if you don't follow me on
twitter i'll say some stuff about them
but then they invent stuff like the the
the ninja bomb that cuts aman al
zawahiri into 10 000 pieces without an
explosive that's dope i don't want to
get all technical that's awesome yes it
is i have one in my garage absolutely
i use it to make a salad though because
i'm a peaceful person
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else